[Music]
all right 606 on your wednesday morning
we are going to tell you about the final
rounds of the nightmare on nellis now of
course that's not the official name for
the project nevada department of
transportation does call it the nellis
boulevard reconstruction project and
most of the time it's not a nightmare
but
when east-west travel on charleston is
completely shut down at nellis when
nellis is down to one lane in each
direction of charleston for two weekends
i think that could be considered
nightmarish now it's not this weekend
but a heads up it's the two following
weekend so april 15th through the 17th
april 22nd through the 24th eight
o'clock on a friday evening scheduled to
run until six the following monday
morning now we've told you about this
before want to make sure you know the
overall aim is the repaving of 10 miles
of nellis trop on the south craig on the
north hopefully you've seen some of that
work already done when it's all finished
of course they're going to be new
pedestrian safety features school zone
upgrades lighting improvements also part
of the big picture we do have a link to
ndot's page on the project in the online
version of this and all of our stories
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy please buckle up drive
carefully and put down the phone
something's driving you crazy here's the
email address traffic 8 at
dot
8newsnow.com